what spirit body I'm aiming from from
Finity and welcome to another episode of
challenge infinity this the series where
you've challenged us with your craziest
ideas related to table tennis we'll go
through all of your comments pick the
most creative ones and make a video out
of them if you're a jagged stick we'll
feature it and give it a shout-out so
make sure to leave your ideas in comment
section below
ownership and a wants to place a bottle
on the edge of the table and hit the
bottle with a ping pong ball to make it
flick
[Music]
[Music]
Piranesi OTRS wants me to spin a coin
with a ping-pong ball this time I'll try
to do it with a serve
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Madison Surratt wants to put six cups on
the table I've made a pyramid out of
them and we'll have to do six different
serves to land the balls inside the cups
Madison let's do this Joe pip wants me
to eat the whole meal while keeping the
ball in the air with my paddle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now the burger is down but it I think
it'd be worse to steal a head
oh I lost my concentration for a tenth
of a second and then that's how it goes
oh well that was the first one
[Music]
[Applause]
then away when the price are down so
just to finish the drink ah so close
get out with the second fail let's
finish this now
[Music]
all right so that was two fails and a
bit disappointed I have to say but
actually it's not too bad it's it's so
difficult to focus on many things at the
same time thanks for watching guys if
you enjoyed this episode make sure to
leave it a thumbs up and if you're new
to the channel subscribe right here and
watch the previous episodes here until
next time